[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
yeah so far hundreds and hundreds of
challengers not one winner no one's
found a mistake I don't know how we do
it yeah
with this kind of excellent time yeah
mr. snappy banter yes snappy banter
timings everything we tell are we still
doing the show yeah kinda tonight we're
kind of doing what no true people try
and look for mistakes so far no one's
caught us making a mistake we haven't
made one mole tonight this is exciting a
fan in Canada that seems to be the theme
this evening don't pretend you're from
there a fan in Canada named Jana is it
yeah now or yeah new problem a new I
think yeah new okay who cares a fan in
Canada named yeah new thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent comedy bit hey Conan yeah new
here I'm in beautiful British Columbia
Canada
I'm out here planting trees on Vancouver
Island I want to talk about a mistake
that I uh that I saw watching Team Coco
last night it was on a segment called
BuzzFeed is running out list so in that
segment there was 12 bumpy things that
are Square Wars and Umbro 12 bumpy
things that are swear words in Braille
that guy
see that guy actually it's Andy that
made a mistake on that one he referred
to the pumpkin as a melon and it's
clearly a pumpkin there's no such thing
as bumpy melon
so you guys there you go I was a mistake
I need to go back to where right now
because I'm actually doing something
that matters
no no I I got this okay first of all
yeah new I hate to tell you but that is
not how you plant trees that's called
that's cost ya Oh making a fire
those will not grow yeah new you can't
just chop them up and make a big stack
but good luck with that second you
corrected Andy by saying the man in the
photos holding a pumpkin well guess what
that is not a pumpkin all right
and third ya knew you said there's no
such thing as a bumpy melon well here's
an expert to prove you wrong
hi I'm dr. Morgan wasteman chief of
dermatology at cedars-sinai Medical
Center Andy was right
every melon goes through a bumpy phase
it happens when they hit melon puberty
emergent bumps nodules and pimples on
this watermelon for instance our moans
called androgens have caused this melons
follicular glands to grow larger and
make more sebum there are other signs of
puberty as well like these braces
another mistake you made yawn who is
that you think your work matters the
truth is that every tree you're planting
will be used to produce millions of
copies of this calendars the losers of
that pee variety
[Applause]
that doctor went a little too far he
kind of seems like a jerk
I suspect he's an actor or even a writer
pretending he's an actor all right
[Laughter]
the point is yeni was wrong yes we're
still undefeated and the challenge still
stands if you think you've spotted an
error on our show reported it team
koco.com / ha ha I found an error we'll
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro
[Applause]